ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN
AND WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
EVENING. OR AFTERNOON? I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IS, WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE STATE CAPITOL, IN ROOM 113.
WE ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE JOIN US, TO BE
HERE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL WE ARE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. TODAY WE HAVE TWO BILLS
ON THE AGENDA. WE HAVE AB 518 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND AB 2496
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN,
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM,
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN AND WE HAVE OUR FIRST
AUTHOR IN THE ROOM, AND WE WILL
HAVE YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PELLERIN, PRESENT AB 2496. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 2496.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS UPFRONT THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING
THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THE SITUATION IS
URGENT AND DIRE. FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
THE CARE OF SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN. I
INTRODUCED AB 2496 TO ENSURE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES WOULD NOT
LOSE THEIR LIABILITY INSURANCE
THIS YEAR, LEADING TO
DISPLACEMENT OF THE 9000
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE NONPROFITS
INSURANCE ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA, NYACK, WHICH INSURES
90% OF FAS, ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK
IT WILL NOT RENEW INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR ALL FAS IN THE
STATE. EARLIER THIS YEAR,
NYACK'S REINSURER PHILADELPHIA
BASED GUY CARPENTER AND COMPANY
LLC SAID IT WOULD NO LONGER
RE-INSURE NYACK IF IT CONTINUED
TO INSURE FAS DUE TO INCREASED
LIABILITY. I JOIN INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
HIS CALL TO ACTION TO URGE ALL
PROPERTY AND CASUALTY INSURANCE
COMPANIES OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA TO FIND A WAY TO
OFFER COVERAGE TO FAS AND HELP
STABILIZE THE STATE'S FOSTER
SYSTEM. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
STRESS THAT AB 2496 IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO KEEP OUR
MOST VULNERABLE FOSTER KIDS IN
THEIR CURRENT HOMES, AND I HOPE
THAT ALL STAKEHOLDERS CAN WORK
TOGETHER BETWEEN NOW AND JANUARY
2025 AND COME BACK WITH AN
URGENCY BILL TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUED OPERATION OF FAS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO, AB 2496 IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO KEEP THOSE
KIDS IN THEIR CURRENT HOMES. THE
BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING FOUR
THINGS. WITH THE JANUARY 1ST,
2027 SUNSET DATE. SECTION ONE
PROVIDES THAT AN FFA SHALL NOT
INDEMNIFY A PUBLIC ENTITY FOR
HARMS CAUSED BY THE ENTITY'S OWN
NEGLIGENT OR INTENTIONAL ACTS.
SECTIONS TWO AND THREE
FACILITATE THE TRANSFER OF
RESOURCE FAMILIES FROM AN FFA
THAT CAN NO LONGER OPERATE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE TO THE COUNTY, OR AN
FFA THAT IS STILL INSURED AND
OPERATIONAL. SECTION FOUR
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
REPORT DATA AND POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
SECTION FIVE CREATES AN URGENCY.
SO I AM PLEASED TO HAVE WITH ME
IN SUPPORT. AMANDA KIRCHNER, WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCACY FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I ALSO HAVE AN
EXPERT WITNESS HERE, CHRIS
STONER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES, WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR PILLAR. AND I DO
NOTE THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. SO IF WE CAN CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR LEMON HERE.
SENATOR LEMON HERE. OCHOA OCHOA.
BOGH HERE. BLAKE SPEER. HURTADO
MENGIBAR HERE. MENGIBAR HERE.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM. PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD
EVENING. AMANDA KIRCHNER, ON
BEHALF OF WTA. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2496. FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES ARE A KEY PARTNER FOR
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS. AND OUR CONTINUUM
OF CARE. THERE IS CURRENTLY
ABOUT 9700 FOSTER CHILDREN THAT
ARE PLACED THROUGH FAS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. COUNTIES OFTEN
CONTRACT WITH THESE FAS TO PLACE
HIGHER NEEDS YOUTH, AS WELL AS
TO PROVIDE ADOPTION SERVICES AND
OTHER SUPPORTS FOR OUR RESOURCE
FAMILIES. 90% OF THE FAS ARE
CURRENTLY COVERED THROUGH ONE
INSURANCE GROUP, WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY, AS WE'VE HEARD,
HAS NOW DECIDED TO NOT RENEW
THEIR COVERAGE MOVING FORWARD.
IF THESE FAS ARE UNABLE TO FIND
REPLACEMENT INSURANCE COVERAGE,
THEY WILL BE FORCED TO CLOSE,
PUTTING THEIR RESOURCE FAMILIES
AND THEIR FOSTER YOUTH IN
UNCERTAINTY. IF FFA IS CLOSED,
THOSE FAMILIES AND FOSTER
CHILDREN WILL NEED TO BE MOVED
BACK UNDER COUNTY JURISDICTION
OR PORTED BACK TO THE COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE DEPARTMENTS. THIS
PROCESS IS FAIRLY UNCOMMON RIGHT
NOW, AND IT CAN TAKE SEVERAL
MONTHS. SO THAT IS TIME THAT WE
WILL NOT HAVE. IF FAS LOSE THEIR
INSURANCE IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
AND CANNOT OBTAIN REPLACEMENT
INSURANCE. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT A SOLUTION
TO THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM. OUR
HOPE IS THAT FAS WILL BE ABLE TO
FIND REPLACEMENT INSURANCE, AND
THAT THERE WILL BE NO
INSTABILITY FOR THESE FAMILIES,
OR A NEED TO PORT THEM FROM AN
FFA TO ANOTHER FFA, OR FROM AN
FFA TO OUR COUNTIES. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE CAUSE AS LITTLE
DISRUPTION AS POSSIBLE FOR THESE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE ALREADY
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA THAT,
FRANKLY, MOST OF US WILL NEVER
UNDERSTAND. AS WE MOVE FORWARD,
AB 29 2496 HELPS COUNTIES BY
ALLOWING DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO WAIVE CURRENT
WRITTEN GUIDELINES REGARDING THE
PORTING PROCESS, AND IT ENSURES
COUNTIES AND FAS CAN DO THIS
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
TRANSITION THOSE FAMILIES. IT
ALSO ENABLES COUNTIES TO
CONTINUE TO PAY THE HIGHER FFA
RATE FOR THOSE FAMILIES THAT
MOVE BACK UNDER COUNTY
JURISDICTION. WHILE THE BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
ISSUE OF THE INSURANCE
AFFORDABILITY, IT DOES REQUIRE
DSS TO ENGAGE WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS MOVING FORWARD, AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT AND PLEDGE TO
BE A PART OF THAT PROCESS. WE
THINK THIS IS JUST A NECESSARY
FIRST STEP. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE AMENDMENTS. I
WANT TO THANK THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER, RICARDO LARA, AND
I WANT TO THANK DIRECTOR KIM
JOHNSON FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS, AS WELL AS THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE SENATE HERE, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL HAVE
THE NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT. TWO
MINUTES, PLEASE. THANK YOU.
CHAIR LEMMON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TONIGHT. MY
NAME IS CHRIS STONER MERTZ. I'M
THE CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES, REPRESENTING OVER 160
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WORK WITH CHILDREN, YOUTH AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE. MANY
OF THESE NONPROFITS ARE FAS OR
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES, A
LIFELINE OF SPECIALIZED CARE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WITH THE MOST
INTENSIVE NEEDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THERE ARE 99,700
VULNERABLE FOSTER YOUTH IN FFA
ACROSS THE STATE. THEY PROVIDE
24 OVER SEVEN SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES TO RESOURCE FAMILIES.
REUNIFICATION SUPPORTS
SUPERVISED VISITATION AND
ASSISTANCE WITH EVERYTHING FROM
TRANSPORTATION, MEDICAL CARE,
COORDINATION AND RESPITE CARE
FOR FAMILIES. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO PROVIDE CLOSE
TO 100% OF INTENSIVE SERVICES.
FOSTER CARE A PROGRAM THAT
ADDRESSES THE MOST COMPLEX NEEDS
OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THE
WRAPAROUND 24 OVER SEVEN
SERVICES PROVIDED BY FAS KEEPS
FOSTER CHILDREN IN FAMILY BASED
CARE, RATHER THAN IN HIGHER
LEVEL SERVICES. THERE IS REALLY
NOTHING LIKE THEM IN OUR STATE.
THE FFA INSURANCE CRISIS HAS HIT
OUR MEMBERS HEAD ON, AND WE ARE
PROPOSING WE'VE PROPOSED
MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS. BOTH SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM. WHILE AB 2496 DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE CRISIS LONG TERM, IT
IS TEMPORARY AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS THAT
ONLY FOCUSING ON EXPEDITING THE
PORTING PROCESS WILL RESULT IN
FFA CAPACITY LOSS THAT WE WON'T
BE ABLE TO REPLACE. WE NEED REAL
SOLUTIONS AND WE URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK WITH US THIS
FALL AND PUT FORWARD
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. WE MAY HAVE
AS MANY AS 3200 FOSTER YOUTH AT
RISK BY THE END OF DECEMBER. IF
WE DON'T, WE DO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN'S EFFORTS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THROUGH
LEGISLATION, EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW
IT WON'T ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES
OF THE INSURANCE CRISIS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION THAT
BOTH DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA HAVE
GIVEN TO THIS ISSUE, AND LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE ENGAGEMENT FROM
THEM. THESE ARE KIDS WHO COULD
POTENTIALLY END UP WITHOUT FFA
SUPPORT IN OUR FUTURE. HOMELESS
CAMPS, ENCAMPMENTS, AND OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM OR
WORSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM? PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. KIM LEWIS
REPRESENTING ESPERANZA, ONE OF
THE FFA WHOSE INSURANCE EXPIRES
IN MID-DECEMBER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JUSTIN GEYER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WERE SORT OF IN THE
MIDDLE OF CSAC, ALONG WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DROPPING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
COUNTIES ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS CRISIS AND DESPITE
OUR ONGOING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INDEMNIFICATION PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL, WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR THE PROVISIONS THAT
WILL HELP COUNTIES EFFECTIVELY
RESPOND TO THIS CRISIS IN THE
SHORT TERM AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING ENGAGEMENT. THANK
YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. THANKS,
MADAM CHAIR. JEAN HEARST, ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, WE'RE IN A SIMILAR
POSITION TO CSAC IN THAT WE'VE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION,
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK, AND
WILL CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE AS
THE DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE THROUGH
THE INTERIM. GREAT. THANK YOU.
SO WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT AND
TWEENERS ANY, ANY OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OPPOSITION,
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS.
ANY COMMENTS? QUESTIONS? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES I WOULD.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO THANK MY
CHIEF OF STAFF, ASHLEY LABAR,
WHO'S PUT IN COUNTLESS HOURS ON
THIS, COMING UP WITH SOME
RESOLUTION, WE'RE DOING THIS FOR
THE KIDS. WE'VE GOT MORE THAN
9000. WHAT? THEY SAY 9700 FOSTER
YOUTH THAT ARE IN A DIRE
SITUATION OF HAVING TO REVERT
BACK TO THE CARE OF THE COUNTIES
IF WE DO NOT DO SOMETHING TO
KEEP THEM IN THEIR HOMES. SO
PLEASE VOTE AYE ON AB 2496.
PLEASE DO IT FOR THE CHILDREN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PELLERIN. ALL RIGHT. SO,
MEMBERS, DO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
AB 2496, WE HAVE A SENATOR
HURTADO WHO HAS MADE THE MOTION
TO MOVE AB 2496. CAN WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WITH THE MOTION
WHILE ITEM TWO AB 2496 MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. ORDERED TO THIRD
READING. SENATOR LAMONI. AYE.
SENATOR LAMONI. AYE. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. BLAKE SPEER. HURTADO.
HURTADO AYE. MENGIBAR CAN WE
JUST CALL THAT ROLL ONE MORE
TIME? SINCE TWO MEMBERS GET TO.
WE'RE ON FILE ITEM TWO, AB 2496.
MOTION. IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. ORDERED TO THIRD
READING. BLAKE SPEER, A BLAKE
SPEER I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS
FIVE ZERO. SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS WITH
AB 518. THANK YOU MADAM. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. IS THE MIC ON?
YEAH, MIC IS ON. OKAY. THIS
SEAT'S A LITTLE SHORT. I FEEL
LIKE I'M LIKE A LITTLE KID AT
THE BIG KIDS TABLE. OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU. OKAY, GOOD. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 518 THIS EVENING.
ENSURING FOOD ACCESS AND FOOD
SECURITY REQUIRES IMMEDIATE AND
COLLECTIVE ACTION. CALFRESH IS
100% FEDERALLY FUNDED, AND EACH
YEAR, THE STATE COULD COULD BE
LEAVING VALUABLE FEDERAL DOLLARS
ON THE TABLE. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO PERSON WHO IS
ELIGIBLE GOES TO BED HUNGRY. AB
518 RECENT AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES BY JULY 1ST, 2025, AND
IN CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS, TO DEVELOP A
FRAMEWORK TO CALCULATE WHO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH AND TO USE
THAT INFORMATION TO PUBLISH DATA
AND METRICS TO DEVELOP TARGETED
OUTREACH STRATEGIES. THE BILL
ALSO MARKS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
ARE COORDINATED, AS THE BILL
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO DATA SHARE
WITH OTHER STATE AND LOCAL
ENTITIES TO IMPROVE AND IDENTIFY
WHO MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH.
BY EXPANDING OUR ABILITY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA, WE CAN CRAFT A
HOLISTIC PLAN THAT TACKLES THE
ROOT CAUSES OF FOOD INSECURITY
AND CREATE SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE? TWO MINUTES. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES AS
TWEENERS OR IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK AND
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
HURTADO. AND WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. JUST
QUICKLY. IS THIS THE BILL THAT
WE HEARD IN COMMITTEE THAT'S
BEEN MODIFIED, THAT USED TO
DELIVER FOOD TO PEOPLE ON THE
STREET? NO, THAT'S A SEPARATE
BILL. OKAY. YEAH. OKAY. THIS
CAME MORE RECENTLY AS A PRIORITY
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION. OKAY.
THANK YOU. I HAVE THREE FOOD
BILLS NOW. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PRESENTING. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE US FOR A VOTE? GREAT
THANK YOU. SO WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND CALL AND MAKE SORRY CALL THE
ROLL FOR THAT ONE FINAL ITEM ONE
AB 518. MOTION IS DUE PASS. BUT
REREFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SENATOR LIMÓN AYE.
SENATOR LIMÓN AYE. ECHO BORG. TO
WICKS BILL. THAT'S ALL YOU NEED
TO KNOW, SENATOR JOE. SENATOR
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. FIVE
TO. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR
HUMAN SERVICES. THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND ADJOURN.